and there's a nice diagram on the back
almost seven years after the UK voted to
leave the EU battles over brexit are
still not over I'm going to make a brief
statement as today the ERG group of Tori
you're a Skeptics rubbish Rishi sunak's
latest deal EU law will still be Supreme
in Northern Ireland the Stormont break
is practically useless
and the framework itself has no exit
other than through a highly complex
legal process although they stop short
of saying they'd oppose it in Parliament
let's have wait till we've got our
meeting tomorrow in every Pharmacy Rishi
sunax wins a framework was intended to
reduce checks on goods between Great
Britain and Northern Ireland at the
heart of it the storm and break if the
break is pulled the UK government will
have a veto a mechanism to give the
Northern Ireland assembly more of a say
over how EU law applies in Northern
Ireland
but it's not enough for the influential
Democratic unionist party we're not in a
position to endorse The Windsor
framework that continued opposition
means Northern Ireland's assembly hasn't
sat for more than a year even though
most politicians outstormant back the
New Deal
and some experts were impressed by what
the PM negotiated I was surprised at
some of the things they have been able
to secure I do think it is a change from
from where we have been it does address
many of the concerns and I think if you
look at the response of businesses in
Northern Ireland generally they're
welcomed and been been optimistic about
the benefits
we'll have to wait until tomorrow
afternoon to see the size of the
Rebellion here in Parliament to see
whether members of the ERG abstain or
vote against the government and indeed
to see whether they move on block but if
there are a small number of rebels let's
say 10 to 20 MPS that won't just be a
relief for Rishi sunak it would also
perhaps suggest the ERG are now a bit of
a spent Force
labor support will guarantee a
government win in the Commons but at
stormant Power sharing still seems a
Long Way Away Joe Pike Sky News